The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: Hey, everybody.
It's my pleasure
once again to welcome
TB Schardl, who is the author
of your taper compiler,
to talk about the
Cilk runtime system.
TAO SCHARDL: Thanks, Charles.
Can anyone hear me in
the back, seem good?
OK.
Thanks for the introduction.
Today I'll be talking about
the Cilk runtime system.
This is pretty exciting for me.
This is a lecture that's
not about compilers.
I get to talk about something
a little different for once.
It should be a fun lecture.
Recently, as I
understand it, you've
been looking at
storage allocation,
both in the serial case as
well as the parallel case.
And you've already done Cilk
programming for a while,
at this point.
This lecture, honestly,
is a bit of a non
sequitur in terms of the
overall flow of the course.
And it's also an advanced topic.
The Cilk runtime system is
a pretty complicated piece
of software.
But nevertheless, I believe you
should have enough background
to at least start to
understand and appreciate
some of the aspects of the
design of the Cilk runtime
system.
So that's why we're
talking about that today.
Just to quickly recall
something that you're all,
I'm sure, intimately familiar
with by this point, what's
Cilk programming all about?
Well, Cilk is a parallel
programming language
that allows you to make
your software run faster
using parallel processors.
And to use Cilk, it's
pretty straightforward.
You may start with
some serial code that
runs in some running time--
we'll denote that as Ts
for certain parts
of the lecture.
If you wanted to run
in parallel using Cilk,
you just insert Cilk
keywords in choice locations.
For example, you can
parallelize the outer loop
in this matrix multiply kernel,
and that will let your code run
in time Tp on P processors.
And ideally, Tp should
be less than Ts.
Now, just adding
keywords is all you
need to do to tell
Cilk to execute
the computation in parallel.
What does Cilk do in
light of those keywords?
At a very high level, Cilk and
specifically its runtime system
takes care of the task
of scheduling and load
balancing the computation
on the parallel processors
and on the multicore
system in general.
So after you've denoted logical
parallel in the program using
spawn, Cilk spawn, Cilk
sync, and Cilk four,
the Cilk scheduler
maps that computation
onto the processors.
And it does so
dynamically at runtime,
based on whatever
processing resources happen
to be available, and still
uses a randomized work stealing
scheduler which guarantees
that that mapping is efficient
and the execution
runs efficiently.
Now you've all been using the
Cilk platform for a while.
In its basic usage, you write
some Cilk code, possibly
by parallelizing
ordinary serial code,
you feed that to a
compiler, you get a binary,
you run the binary the binary
with some particular input
on a multicore system.
You get parallel performance.
Today, we're going to look at
how exactly does Cilk work?
What's the magic
that goes on, hidden
by the boxes on this diagram?
And the very first thing to
note is that this picture
is a little bit--
the first simplification
that we're going to break
is that it's not really just
Cilk source and the Cilk
compiler.
There's also a runtime system
library, libcilkrts.so, in case
you've seen that
file or messages
about that file on your system.
And really it's the compiler
and the runtime library,
that work together to implement
Cilk's runtime system,
to do the work stealing and
do the efficient scheduling
and load balancing.
Now we might suspect that if
you just take a look at the code
that you get when you
compile a Cilk program,
that might tell you something
about how Cilk works.
Here's C pseudocode for the
results when you compile
a simple piece of Cilk code.
It's a bit complicated.
I think that's fair to say.
There's a lot going on here.
There is one function
in the original program,
now there are two.
There's some new
variables, there's
some calls to functions that
look a little bit strange,
there's a lot going on
in the compiled results.
This isn't exactly easy to
interpret or understand,
and this doesn't even bring into
the picture the runtime system
library.
The runtime system library,
you can find the source
code online.
It's a little less than
20,000 lines of code.
It's also kind of complicated.
So rather than dive
into the code directly,
what we're going to
do today is an attempt
at a top-down approach
to understanding
how the Cilk runtime
system works,
and some of the
design considerations.
So we're going to start
by talking about some
of the required functionality
that we need out of the Cilk
runtime system, as well
as some performance
considerations for how the
runtime system should work.
And then we'll take a look at
how the worker deques in Cilk
get implemented, how
spawning actually works,
how stealing a
computation works,
and how synchronization
works within Cilk.
That all sound good?
Any questions so far?
This should all be
review, more or less.
OK, so let's talk a little bit
about required functionality.
You've seen this
picture before, I hope.
This picture illustrated
the execution model
of a Cilk program.
Here we have everyone's favorite
exponential time Fibonacci
routine, parallelized
using Cilk.
This is not an efficient way
to compute Fibonacci numbers,
but it's a nice didactic
example for understanding
parallel computation,
especially the Cilk model.
And as we saw many
lectures ago, when
you run this program
on a given input,
the execution of
the program can be
modeled as a computation dag.
And this computation
dag unfolds dynamically
as the program executes.
But I want to stop
and take a hard look
at exactly what that dynamic
execution looks like when we've
got parallel processors and work
stealing all coming into play.
So we'll stick with
this Fibonacci routine,
and we'll imagine we've just
got one processor on the system,
to start.
And we're just going
to use this one
processor to execute fib(4).
And it's going to take
some time to do it,
just to make the
story interesting.
So we start executing
this computation,
and that one processor is just
going to execute the Fibonacci
routine from beginning up
to the Cilk spawn statement,
as if it's ordinary
serial code, because it
is ordinary serial code.
At this point the processor
hits the Cilk spawn statement.
What happens now?
Anyone remember?
What happens to the dag?
AUDIENCE: It branches
down [INAUDIBLE]
TAO SCHARDL: It branches
downward and spawns
another process, more or less.
The way we model that--
the Cilk spawn is of a
routine fib of n minus 1.
In this case, that'll be fib(3).
And so, like an
ordinary function call,
we're going to get a brand
new frame for fib(3).
And that's going to
have some strand that's
available to execute.
But the spawn is not your
typical function call.
It actually allows some other
computation to run in parallel.
And so the way we model
that in this picture
is that we get a new
frame for fib(3).
There's a strand available
to execute there.
And the continuation,
the green strand,
is now available in
the frame fib(4).
But no one's necessarily
executing it.
It's just kind of
faded in the picture.
So once the spawn
has occurred, what's
the processor going to do?
The processor is actually
going to dive in and start
executing fib(3), as if it
were an ordinary function call.
Yes, there's a strand available
within the frame of fib(4),
but the processor isn't going
to worry about that strand.
It's just going to say,
oh, fib(4) calls fib(3),
going to start
computing for fib(3).
Sound good?
And so the processor
dives down from pink
strand to pink strand.
The instruction pointer
for the processor
returns to the beginning
of the fib routine,
because we're now
calling fib once again.
And this process repeats.
It executes the pink strand
up until the Cilk spawn,
just like ordinary serial code.
The spawn occurs-- and we've
already seen this picture
before--
the spawn allows another
strand to execute in parallel.
But it also creates
a frame for fib(2).
And the processor
dives into fib(2),
resetting the instruction
pointer to the beginning fib,
P1 executes up to the spawn.
Once again, we get
another string to execute,
as well as an
invocation of fib(1).
Processor dives even further.
So that's fine.
This is just the processor
doing more or less
ordinary serial execution
of this fib routine,
but it's also
allowing some strands
to be executed in parallel.
This is the one
processor situation,
looks pretty good so far.
Right, and in the
fib(1) case, it
doesn't make it as far
through the pink strand
because, in fact, we
hit the base case.
But now let's bring in
some more processors.
Suppose that another
processor finally
shows up, says I'm bored,
I want to do some work,
and decides to steal
some computation.
It's going to discover the green
strand in the frame fib(4),
and P2 is just going
to jump in there
and start executing that strand.
And if we think really
hard about what this means,
P2 is another processor
on the system.
It has its own set of registers.
It has its own
instruction pointer.
And so what Cilk
somehow allows to happen
is for P2 to just jump
right into the middle
of this fib(4) routine,
which is already executing.
It just sets the
instruction pointer
to point at that
green instruction,
at the call to fib of n minus 2.
And it's just going to pick
up where processor 1 left off,
when it executed up to this
point in fib(4), somehow.
In this case, it executes
fib of n minus 2.
That calls fib(2),
creates a new strand,
it's just an ordinary
function call.
It's going to descend
into that new frame.
It's going to return to
the beginning of fib.
All that's well and good.
Another processor might come
along and steal another piece
of the computation.
It steals another green
strand, and so once again,
this processor needs to jump
into the middle of an executing
function.
Its instruction
pointer is just going
to point at this call
of the fib of n minus 2.
Somehow, it's going to have
the state of this executing
function available, despite
having independent registers.
And it needs to just
start from this location,
with all the parameters
set appropriately,
and start executing
this function
as if it's an ordinary function.
It calls fib(3) minus 2 is 1.
And now these processors might
start executing in parallel.
P1 might return from
its base case routine
up to the parent call
of fib of n minus 2
and start executing
its continuation,
because that wasn't stolen.
Meanwhile, P3 descends into
the execution of fib(1).
And then in another
step, P3 and P2
make some progress
executing their computation.
P2 encounters a Cilk
spawn statement,
which creates a new frame
and allows another strand
to execute in parallel.
P3 encounters the base
case routine and says,
OK, it's time to return.
And all of that can
happen in parallel,
and somehow the Cilk system
has to coordinate all of this.
But we already have one mystery.
How does a processor start
executing from the middle
of a running function?
The running function and it's
state lived on P1 initially,
and then P2 and P3
somehow find that state,
hop into the middle
of the function,
and just start running.
That's kind of strange.
How does that happen?
How does the Cilk runtime
system make that happen?
This is one thing to consider.
Another thing to
consider is what
happens when we hit a sync.
We'll talk about how these
issues get addressed later on,
but let's lay out all of
the considerations upfront,
before we-- just see how
bad the problem is before we
try to solve it bit by bit.
So now, let's take this
picture again and progress it
a little bit further.
Let's suppose that
processor three
decides to execute the return.
It's going to return to
an invocation of fib(3).
And the return statement
is a Cilk sync statement.
But processor three
can't execute the sync
because the computation
of fib(2) in this case--
that's being done
by processor one--
that computation
is not done yet.
So the execution can
proceed past the sync.
So somehow P3 needs to say,
OK, there is a sync statement,
but we can't execute
beyond this point
because, specifically, it's
waiting on processor one.
It doesn't care what
processor two is doing.
Processor two is having a
dandy time executing fib(2)
on the other side of the tree.
Processor three shouldn't care.
So processor three
can't do something
like, OK, all
processors need to stop,
get to this point in the
code, and then the execution
can proceed.
No, no, it just needs to
wait on processor one.
Somehow the Cilk system has
to allow that fine grain
synchronization to happen
in this nested pattern.
So how does a Cilk sync
wait on only the nested sub
computations within the program?
How does it figure
out how to do that?
How does the Cilk runtime
system implement this?
So that's another consideration.
OK, so at this point, we have
three top level considerations.
A single worker needs to be
able to execute this program as
if it's an ordinary
serial program.
Thieves have to be able to jump
into the middle of executing
functions and pick up
from where they left off,
from where other processors
in the system left off.
Syncs have to be able to
stall functions appropriately,
based only on those functions'
nested child sub computations.
So we have three
big considerations
that we need to
pick apart so far.
That's not the
whole story, though.
Any ideas what other
functionality we
need to worry about, for
implementing this Cilk system?
It's kind of an open ended
question, but any thoughts?
We have serial execution,
spawning, stealing, and syncing
as top level concerns.
Anyone remember some
other features of Cilk
that the runtime system
magically makes happen,
correctly?
It's probably been a while
since you've seen those.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Cilk for loops
divide and conquer?
TAO SCHARDL: The Cilk for
loops divide and conquer.
Somehow, the runtime system does
have to implement Cilk fours.
The Cilk fours end up getting
implemented internally,
with spawns and syncs.
That's courtesy of the compiler.
Yeah, courtesy of the compiler.
So we wont look too
hard at Cilk fors today,
but that's definitely
one concern.
Good observation.
Any other thoughts, sort
of low level system details
that Cilk needs to
implement correctly?
Cache coherence--
it actually doesn't
need to worry too much
about cache coherence
although, given the
latest performance numbers
I've seen from Cilk,
maybe it should worry more
about the cache.
But it turns out
the hardware does
a pretty good job maintaining
the cache coherence
protocol itself.
But good guess .
It's not really
a tough question,
because it's really just calling
back memories of old lectures.
I think you recently had
a quiz on this material,
so it's probably safe to say
that all that material has
been paged out of your
brain at this point.
So I'll just spoil
the fun for you.
Cilk has a notion
of a cactus stack.
So we talked a little
bit about processors
jumping into the middle
of an executing function
and somehow having the state
of that function available.
One consideration
is registered state,
but another consideration
is the stack itself.
And Cilk supports the
C's rule for pointers,
namely that children can see
pointers into parent frames,
but parents can't see
pointers into child frames.
Now each processor, each
worker in a Cilk system,
needs to have its own
view of the stack.
But those views aren't
necessarily independent.
In this picture,
all five processors
share the same view of the frame
for Function A instantiation A,
then processors three
through five all share
the same view for the
instantiation of C.
So somehow, Cilk has to
make all of those views
available and consistent
but not quite the same, sort
of consistent as we get
with cache coherence.
Cilk somehow has to
implement this cactus stack.
So that's another consideration
that we have to worry about.
And then there's one more
kind of funny detail.
If we take another look
at work stealing itself--
you may remember we had this
picture from several lectures
ago where we have
processors on the system,
each maintains its
own deck of frames,
and workers are allowed to
steal frames from each other.
But if we take a look
at how this all unfolds,
yes we may have a processor
that performs a call,
and that'll push another
frame for a called function
onto its deque on the bottom.
It may spawn, and that'll
push a spawn frame
onto the bottom of its deck.
But if we fast
forward a little bit
and we get in up with a
worker with nothing to do,
that worker is going
to go ahead and steal,
picking another worker
in the system at random.
And it's going to steal
from the top of the deque.
But it's not just going to steal
the topmost item on the deque.
It's actually going to steal a
chunk of items from the deque.
In particular, if it
selects the third processor
in this picture,
third from the left,
this thief is going
to steal everything
through the parent of
the next spawned frame.
It needs to take this
whole stack of frames,
and it's not clear a
priori how many frames
the worker is going to
have to steal in this case.
But nevertheless, it needs
to take all those frames
and resume execution.
After all, that bottom was a
call frame that it just stole.
That's where there's
a continuation
with work available to
be done in parallel.
And so, if we think
about it, there
are a lot of
questions that arise.
What's involved in
stealing frames?
What synchronization does
this system have to implement?
What happens to the stack?
It looks like we just shifted
some frames from one processor
to another, but the first
processor, the victim,
still needs access to
the data in that stack.
So how does that part work, and
how does any of this actually
become efficient?
So now we have a pretty
decent list of functionality
that we need out of the
Cilk runtime system.
We need serial
execution to work.
We need thieves to be able to
jump into the middle of running
functions.
We need sinks to synchronize
in this nested, fine grain way.
We need to implement a cactus
stack for all the workers
to see.
And these have to deal with
mixtures of spawned frames
and called frames
that may be available
when they steal a computation.
So that's a bunch
of considerations.
Is this the whole picture?
Well, there's a little
bit more to it than that.
So before I give
you an answers, I'm
just going to keep
raising questions.
And now I want to raise
some questions concerning
the performance of the system.
How do we want to
design the system
to get good parallel
execution times?
Well if we take a look at the
work stealing bounds for Cilk,
the Cilk's work
stealing scheduler
achieves an expected
running time of Tp,
on P processors, which is
proportional to the work
of the computation divided
by the number of processors,
plus something on the order of
the span of the computation.
Now if we take a look at
this running time bound,
we can decompose
it into two pieces.
The T1 over P part,
that's really the time
that the parallel workers on the
system spend doing actual work.
They're P of those workers,
they're all making progress
on the work of the computation.
That comes out to
T of one over P.
The other part of the bound,
order T infinity, that's
a time that turns out to
be the time that workers
spend stealing computation
from each other.
And ideally, what we want when
we paralyze a program using
Cilk, is we want to see this
program achieve linear speedup.
That means that if we give the
program more processors to run,
if we increase P, we want
to see the execution time
decrease, linearly, with P.
And that means we want the of
the workers in the Cilk system
to spend most of the
time doing useful work.
We don't want the workers
spending a lot of time
stealing from each other.
In fact, we want
even more than this.
We don't just want work divided
by number of processors.
We really care about how
the performance compares
to the running time of
the original serial code
that we were given,
that we parallelized.
That original serial
code ran in time Ts of S.
And now we paralyze it
using Cilk spawn, Cilk sync,
or in this case, Cilk for.
And ideally, with
sufficient parallelism,
we'll guarantee that
the running time is
going to be Ts of P proportional
to the work of a processor, T1
divided by P. But we really
want to speed up compared
to Ts of S. So that's our goal.
We want Tp to be proportional
to Ts of S over P.
That says that we want
the serial running time
to be pretty close to the work
of the parallel computation.
So the one processor running
time of our Cilk code, ideally,
should look pretty close
to the running time
of the original serial code.
So just to put these
pieces together,
if we were originally
given a serial program that
ran on time Ts of S, and we
parallelize it using Cilk,
we end up with a parallel
program with work T1
and span T infinity.
We want to achieve linear
speed up on P processors,
compared to the original
serial running time.
In order to do that,
we need two things.
We need ample parallelism.
T1 one over T infinity should
be a lot bigger than P.
And we've seen why that's
the case in lectures past.
We also want what's called
high work efficiency.
We want the ratio of the
serial running time divided
by the work of the
still computation
to be pretty close to
one, as close as possible.
Now, the Cilk runtime system
is designed with these two
observations in mind.
And in particular, the
Cilk runtime system
says, suppose that we
have a Cilk program that
has ample parallelism.
It has efficient
parallelism to make
good use of the available
parallel processors.
Then in implementing
the Cilk runtime,
we have a goal to maintain
high work efficiency.
And to maintain high
work efficiency,
the Cilk runtime
system abides by what's
called the work first
principle, which
is to optimize the
ordinary serial execution
of the program, even at the
expense of some additional cost
to steals.
Now at 30,000 feet, the way
that the Cilk runtime system
implements the work
first principle
and makes all these
components work
is by dividing the job
between both the compiler
and the runtime system library.
The compiler uses a handful
of small data structures,
including workers
and stack frames,
and implements
optimized fast paths
for execution of
functions, which should be
executed when no steals occur.
The runtime system
library handles issues
with the parallel execution.
And uses larger data structures
that maintain parallel
running time state.
And it handles slower
paths of execution,
in particular when
seals actually occur.
So those are all
the considerations.
We have a lot of
functionality requirements
and we have some
performance considerations.
We want to optimize
the work, even
at the expense of some steals.
Let's finally take a
look at how Cilk works.
How do we deal with
all these problems?
I imagine some you may have
some ideas as to how you might
tackle one issue or another, but
let's see what really happens.
Let's start from the beginning.
How do we implement
a worker deque?
Now for this
discussion, we're going
to use a running example
with just a really, really
simple, Cilk routine.
It's not even as
complicated as fib.
We're going to have a function
foo that, at one point,
spawns a function bar, in
the continuation calls baz,
performs a sync,
and then returns.
And just to establish
some terminology,
foo will be what we call
a spawning function,
meaning that foo is capable
of executing a Cilk spawn
statement.
The function bar
is spawned by foo.
We can see that from the
Cilk spawn in front of bar.
And the call to baz occurs in
the continuation of that Cilk
spawn, simple picture.
Everyone good so far?
Any questions about the
functionality requirements,
terminology, performance
considerations?
OK.
So now we're going to take a
hard look at just one worker
and we're going to
say, conceptually, we
have this deque-like structure
which has spawned frames
and called frames.
Let's ignore the rest of
the workers on the system.
Let's not worry about--
well, we'll worry a little
bit about how steals can work,
but we're just going
to focus on the actions
that one worker performs.
How do we implement this deque?
And we want the worker to
operate on its own deck,
a lot like a stack.
It's going to push and
pop frames from the bottom
up the deque.
Steals need to be
able to transfer
ownership of several
consecutive frames
from the top of the deque.
And thieves need to be able
to resume a continuation.
So the way that the
Cilk system does this,
to bring this concept
into an implementation,
is that it's going to
implement the deque externally
from the actual call stack.
Those frames will still
be in a stack somewhere
and they'll be managed,
roughly speaking,
with a standard
calling convention.
But the worker is going to
maintain a separate deque data
structure, which will contain
pointers into this stack.
And the worker itself
will maintain the deque
using head and tail pointers.
Now in addition to this
picture, the frames
that are available
to be stolen--
the frames that have
computation that a thief can
come along and execute--
those frames will store an
additional local structure
that will contain information
as necessary for stealing
to occur.
Does this make sense?
Questions so far?
Ordinary call stack,
deque lives outside of it,
worker points at the deque,
pretty simple design.
So I mentioned that the compiler
used relatively lightweight
structures.
This is essentially one of them.
And if we take a look at the
implementation of the Cilk
runtime system, this
is the essence of it.
There are some additional
implementation details,
but these are the core--
this is, in a sense, the
core piece of the design.
So the rest is just details.
The Intel Cilk
Plus runtime system
takes this design and elaborates
on it in a variety of ways.
And we're going to take a
look at those elaborations.
First off, what
we'll see is that
every spawned
subcomputation ends up
being executed within its
own helper function, which
the compiler will generate.
That's called a spawn
helper function.
And then the runtime
system is going
to maintain a few basic data
structures as the workers
execute their work.
There'll be a structure
for the worker, which
will look similar to what we
just saw in the previous slide.
There'll be a Cilk
stack frame structure
for each instantiation
of a spawning function,
some function that
can perform and spawn.
And there'll be a
stack-frame structure
for each spawn helper, each
instantiation that is spawned.
Now if we take another
look at the compiled code
we had before, some of it
starts to make some sense.
Originally, we had our spawning
function foo and a statement
that spawned off, called a bar.
And in the C pseudocode
of the compiled results,
we see that we
have two functions.
The first function foo--
that's our spawning function--
it's got a bunch of stuff
in it, and we'll figure out
what that's doing in a second.
But there's a second function,
and that second function
is the spawn helper.
And that spawn helper
actually contains
a statement which calls bar and
ultimately saves the result.
Make sense?
Now we're starting to understand
some of the confusing C
pseudocode we saw before.
And if we take a look at each
of these routines we see,
indeed, there is a
stack frame structure.
And so in Intel Cilk Plus it's
called a Cilk RTS stack frame,
very creative name, I know.
And it's just added as
an extra local variable
in each of these functions.
You got one inside of
foo, because that's
a spawning function, and you get
one inside of the spawn helper.
Now if we dive into the Cilk
stack frame structure itself,
by cracking open the source
code for the Intel Cilk Plus
runtime, we see that there are a
lot of fields in the structure.
The main fields are as follows--
there is a buffer, a context
buffer, and that's going to
contain enough information
to resume a function
at a continuation,
particularly to mean after
a Cilk spawn or, in fact,
after a Cilk sync statement.
There's an additional integer
in the stack frame called flags,
which will summarize the
state of the Cilk stack rate,
and we'll see a little
bit more about that later.
And there's going to be a
pointer to a parent Cilk stack
frame that's somewhere above
this Cilk RTS stack frame,
somewhere in the call stack.
So these Cilk RTS
stack frames, these
are the extra bit of state that
the Cilk runtime system adds
to the ordinary call stack.
So if we take a look at the
actual worker structure,
it's a lot like
what we saw before.
We have a deque that's
external to the call stack.
The Cilk worker maintains head
and tail pointers to the deque.
The Cilk workers are also
going to maintain a pointer
to the current Cilk
RTS stack frame, which
will tend to be somewhere
near the bottom of the stack.
OK, so those are the basic data
structures that a single worker
is going to maintain.
That includes the deque.
Let's see them all
in action, shall we?
Any questions about
that so far, before we
start watching pointers fly?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: I guess with
the previous slide,
there were arrows on
the workers' call stack.
What do you [INAUDIBLE]?
TAO SCHARDL: What do the arrows
among the elements on the call
stack mean?
So in this picture
of the call stack,
function instantiations
are actually in green,
and local variables--
specifically the Cilk RTS stack
frames--
those show up in beige.
So foo SF is the Cilk RTS stack
frame inside the instantiation
of foo.
It's just a local
variable that's also
stored in the stack, right?
Now, the Cilk RTS stack frame
maintains a parent pointer,
and it maintains a pointer
up to some Cilk RTS stack
frame above it on the stack.
It's just another local
variable, also stored
in the stack.
So when we step away and
look at the whole call stack
with all the function frames
and the Cilk RTS stack frames,
that's where we get the
pointers climbing up the stack.
We're good?
Other questions?
All right, let's make
some pointers fly.
OK, this is going to
be kind of a letdown,
because the first thing we're
going to look at is some code.
So we're not going to have
pointers flying just yet.
We can take a look at the code
for the spawning function foo,
at this point.
And there's a lot of extra
code in here, clearly.
I've highlighted a lot
of stuff on this slide,
and all the
highlighted material is
related to the execution
of the Cilk runtime system.
But basically, if we
look at this code,
we can understand
each of these pieces.
Each of them has some role to
play in making the Cilk runtime
system work.
So at the very beginning,
we have our Cilk stack frame
structure.
And there's a call
to this enter frame
function, which all
that really does
is initialize the stack frame.
That's all the
function is doing.
Later on, we find that there's
this set jump routine--
we'll talk a lot more
about set jump in a bit--
that, at this point, we can
say the set jump prepares
the function for a spawn.
And inside the
conditional, where
the set jump occurs
as a predicate,
we have a call to spawn bar.
If we remember from a
couple of slides ago,
spawn bar was our
spawn helper function.
So we're here, we're just
invoking the spawn helper.
Later on in the code,
we have another blob
of conditionals with a Cilk
RTS sync call, deep inside.
All that code performs a sync.
We'll talk about that a bit
near the end of lecture.
And finally, at the end
of the spawning function,
we have a call to pop
frame, which just cleans up
the Cilk stack frame structure
within this function.
And then there's a call to
leave frame, which essentially
cleans up the deque.
That's the spawning function.
This is the spawn helper.
It looks somewhat similar.
I've added extra whitespace
just to make the slide
a little bit prettier.
And in some ways, it's similar
to the spawning function
itself.
We have a Cilk RTS stack frame
[INAUDIBLE] spawn helper,
another call to
enter frame, which
is just a little bit different.
But essentially, it
initializes the stack frame.
Its reason to be is
similar to the enter frame
call we saw before.
There's a call to
Cilk RTS detach,
which performs a bunch
of updates on the deque.
Then there is the
actual invocation
of the spawn subroutine.
This is where we're calling bar.
And finally, at the
end of the function,
there is a call to pop frame,
to clean up the stack structure,
and a call to leave frame,
which will clean up the deck
and possibly return.
It'll try to return.
We'll see more about that.
So let's watch all
of this in action.
Question?
OK, cool.
Let's see all of this in action.
We'll start off with a
pretty boring picture.
All we've got on our
call stack is main,
and our Cilk worker has
nothing on its deque.
But now we suppose that main
calls our responding function
foo, and the
spawning function foo
contains a Cilk RTS stack frame.
What we're going to do in the
Cilk worker, what that enter
frame call is going to
perform, all it's going to do
is update the
current stack frame.
We now have a Cilk
RTS stack frame,
make sure the worker
points at it, that's all.
Fast forward a little
bit, and foo encounters
this call to Cilk spawn a bar.
And in the C pseudocode
that's compiled for foo,
we have a set jump routine.
This set jump is kind
of a magical function.
This is the function
that allows thieves
to steal the continuation.
And in particular, the set
jump takes, as an argument,
a buffer.
In this case, it's
the context buffer
that we have in the
Cilk RTS stack frame.
And what the set
jump will do is it
will store information
that's necessary to resume
the function at the
location of the set jump.
And it stores that
information into the buffer.
Can anyone guess what
that information might be?
AUDIENCE: The instruction
points at [INAUDIBLE]..
TAO SCHARDL: Instruction
pointer or stock pointer,
I believe both of
those are in the frame.
Yeah, both of those
are in the frame.
Good, what else?
AUDIENCE: All the
registers are in use.
TAO SCHARDL: All the registers
are currently in use.
Does it need all the registers?
You're absolutely
on the right track,
but is there any way it could
restrict the set of registers
it needs to save?
AUDIENCE: The registers are
used later in the execution.
TAO SCHARDL: That's part of it.
Set jump isn't
that clever though,
so it just stores a
predetermined set of registers.
But there is another
way to restrict the set.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
TAO SCHARDL: Only
registers uses parameters
in the called function,
yeah, close enough.
Callee-saved registers.
So registers that
the function might--
that it's the responsibility
of foo to save,
this goes all the way back to
that discussion in lecture,
I don't remember which
small number, talking
about the calling convention.
These registers
need to be saved,
as well as the instruction
pointer and various stack
pointers.
Those are what gets
saved into the buffer.
The other registers, well,
we're about to call a function,
it's up to that other
function to save the registers
appropriately.
So we don't need to
worry about those.
So all good?
Any questions about that?
All right, so this
set jump routine,
let's take it for
granted that when
we call a set jump on this
given buffer, it returns zero.
That's a good lie for now.
We'll just run with it.
So set jump returs zero.
The condition
says, if not zero--
which turns out to be true--
and so the next
thing that happens
is this call to the
spawn helper, spawn_bar,
in this case.
When we call spawn_bar,
what happens to our stack?
So this should look
pretty routine.
We're doing a function
call, and so we
push the frame for the called
function onto the stack.
And that called
function, spawn bar,
contains a local
variable, which is
this [INAUDIBLE] stack frame.
So that also gets
pushed onto the stack,
pretty straightforward.
We've seen function
calls many times before.
This should look
pretty familiar.
Now we do this Cilk RTS
enter frame fast routine.
And I mentioned before
that that's going
to update the worker structure.
So what's going to happen here?
Well, we have a brand new Cilk
RTS stack frame on the stack.
Any guesses as to
what change we make?
What would enter frame do?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
TAO SCHARDL: Point
current stack frame
to spawn in bar stack
frame, you're right.
Anything else?
Hope I got this animation right.
What are the various fields
within the stack frame?
And what did-- sorry,
I don't know your name.
What's your name?
AUDIENCE: I'm Greg.
TAO SCHARDL: Greg, what
did Greg ask about before,
when we saw an earlier
picture of the call stack?
AUDIENCE: Set a
pointer to the parent.
TAO SCHARDL: Set a pointer
to the parent, exactly.
So what we're going
to do is we're
going to take this
call stack, we'll
do the enter frame fast routine.
That establishes this parent
pointer in our brand new stack
frame.
And we update the worker's
current stack frame to point
at the bottom.
Yeah, question?
AUDIENCE: How does enter
frame know what the parent is?
TAO SCHARDL: How does enter
Good question.
Enter frame knows the worker.
Or rather, enter frame can do a
call, which will give it access
to the Cilk worker structure.
And because it can
do a call, it can
read the current stack
frame pointer in the worker.
AUDIENCE: So we do
[INAUDIBLE] before we
change the current [INAUDIBLE]?
TAO SCHARDL: Yeah,
in this case we do.
So we add the parent pointer,
then we delete and update.
So, good catch.
Any other questions?
Cool.
All right, now we encounter
this thing, Cilk RTS detach.
This one's kind of exciting.
Finally we get to do
something to the deque.
Any guesses what we do?
How do we update the deque?
Here's a hint.
Cilk RTS detach allows--
this is the function that allows
some computation to be stolen.
Once Cilk RTS detach
is done executing,
a thief could come along
and steal the continuation
of the Cilk spawn.
So what would Cilk RTS
detach do to our worker
and its structures?
Yeah, in the back.
AUDIENCE: Push the stack
frame to the worker deque?
TAO SCHARDL: Push the stack
frame to the worker deque,
specifically at the tail.
Right, I gave it away by
clicking the animation,
oh well.
Now the thing that's available
to be stolen is inside of foo.
So what ends up getting
pushed onto the deque
is not the current
stack frame, but in fact
its immediate parent, so
the stack frame of foo.
That gets pushed onto
the tail of the deque.
And we now push something
onto the tail of a deque.
And so we advance
the tail pointer.
Still good, everyone?
I see some nods.
I see at least one nod.
I'll take it.
But feel free to ask
questions, of course.
And then of course there
is this invocation of bar.
This does what you might expect.
It calls bar, no magic here.
Well, no new magic here.
OK, fast forward, let's suppose
that bar finally returns.
And now we return
to the statement
after bar in the spawn helper.
That statement is the pop frame.
Actually, since we
just returned from bar,
we need to get rid of
bar from the stack frame.
Good, now we can
execute the pop frame.
What would the pop frame do?
It's going to clean up
the stack frame structure.
So what would that
entail, any guesses?
AUDIENCE: I guess it would move
the current stack frame back
to the parent stack frame?
TAO SCHARDL: Move the current
stack frame back to the parent,
very good.
I think that's largely it.
I guess there's one
other thing it can do.
It's kind of optional,
given that it's going
to garbage the memory anyway.
So it updates the current stack
frame to point to the parent,
and now it no longer
needs that parent pointer.
So it can clean that
up, in principle.
And then there's this call
to Cilk RTS leave frame.
This is magic-- well, not
really, but it's not obvious.
This is a function call
that may or may not return.
Welcome to the Cilk
runtime system.
You end up with
calls to functions
that you may never return from.
This happens all the time.
And the Cilk RTS leave
frame may or may not
return, based entirely
on what's on the status
of the deque, what
content is currently
sitting on the workers' deque.
Anyone have a guess as
to why the leave frame
routine might not return,
in the conventional sense?
AUDIENCE: There's nothing
else for the worker to do,
so it'll sit there spinning.
TAO SCHARDL: If there's
nothing left to do on the deck,
then it's going to--
sorry, say again?
AUDIENCE: It'll just wait until
there's work you can steal?
TAO SCHARDL: Right, if
there's nothing on the deque,
then it has nowhere
to return to.
And so naturally, as we've seen
from Cilk workers in the past,
it discovers there's nothing
on the deque, there's no work
to do, time to turn
to a life of crime,
and try to steal work
from someone else.
So there are two
possible scenarios.
The pop could succeed and
execution continues as normal,
or it fails and it
becomes a thief.
Now which of these
two cases do you
think is more important for
the runtime system to optimize?
Success, case one,
exactly, so why is that?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
TAO SCHARDL: At least,
we hope so, yeah.
We assume-- this hearkens all
the way back to that work first
principle--
we assume that in
the common case,
workers are doing
useful work, they're
not just spending their time
stealing from each other.
And therefore, ideally,
we want to assume
that the worker will
do what's normal,
just an ordinary
serial execution.
In a normal serial
execution, there
is something on the deque, the
pop succeeds, that's case one.
So what we'll see is that
the runtime system, in fact,
does a little bit of
optimization on case one.
Let's talk about something
a little more exciting.
How about stealing computation.
We like stealing
stuff from each other.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
TAO SCHARDL: Where does
it return the results?
So where does it return the
result in the spawn bar?
The answer you can kind of
see two lines above this.
So in this case, in
the original Cilk code,
we had X equals
Cilk spawn of bar.
And here, what are the
parameters to our spawn bar
function?
X and N. Now N is the
input to bar, right?
So what's X?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
TAO SCHARDL: You can
rewind a little bit
and see that you are correct.
There we go.
Yeah, so the original Cilk code,
we had X equals Cilk spawn bar.
That's the same X.
All that Cilk does
is pass a pointer to
the memory allocated
for that variable down
to the spawn helper.
And now the spawn helper, when
it calls bar and that returns,
it gets stored into that storage
in the parent stack frame.
Good catch.
Good observation.
Any questions about that?
Does that make sense?
Cool.
Probably used too many
animations in these slides.
All right, now let's
talk about stealing.
How does a worker
steal computation?
Now the conceptual
diagram we had before
saw this one worker, with
nothing on its deque,
take a couple of frames
from another workers deque
and just slide them on over.
What does that actually look
like in the implementation?
Well, we're still going to
take from the top of the deque,
but now we have a picture
that's a little bit more
accurate in terms of the
structures that are really
implemented in the system.
So we have the call
stack of the victim,
and the victim also has a
deque data structure and a Cilk
worker data structure,
with head and tail pointers
and a current stack frame.
So what happens when a thief
comes along out of nowhere?
It's bored, it has
nothing on its deque.
Head and tail pointers
both point to the top.
Current stack frame has nothing.
What's the thief going to do?
Any guesses?
How does this thief
take the content
from the worker's deque?
AUDIENCE: The worker sets
their current stack frame
to the one that [INAUDIBLE]
TAO SCHARDL:
Exactly right, yeah.
Sorry, was that--
I didn't mean to interrupt.
All right, cool.
So the red highlighting should
give a little bit of a hint.
The current stack
frame in the thief
is going to end up
pointing to the stack frame
at the top of the deque, pointed
to by the top of the deque.
And the head of the deque
needs to be updated.
So let's just see all
those pointers shuffle.
The thief is going to target
the head of the deque.
It's going to deque that item
from the top of the deck.
It's going to set the
current stack frame
to point to that item, and
it will delete the pointer
on the deque.
That make sense?
Cool.
Now the victim and the thief
are on different processors,
and this scenario involves
shuffling a lot of pointers
around.
So if we think
about this process,
there needs to be
some way to handle
the concurrent accesses
that are going to occur
on the head of the deque.
You haven't talked
about synchronization
yet in this class, that's going
to be a couple lectures down
the road.
I'll give you a
couple of spoilers
for those
synchronization lectures.
First off, synchronization
is expensive.
And second, reasoning
about synchronization
is a source of
massive headaches.
Congratulations, you now
know those two lectures.
No, I'm just kidding.
Go to the lectures, you'll
learn a lot, they're great.
In the Cilk runtime
system, the way
that those concurrent
accesses are handled
is by using a protocol
known as the THE protocol.
This is pseudo code for most of
the logic in the THE protocol.
There's a protocol that
the worker, executing work
normally, follows.
And there is the
protocol for the thief.
I'm not going to walk
through all the lines of code
here and describe what they do.
I'll just give you the very high
level view of this protocol.
From the thief's
perspective, the thief
always grabs a lock on the deque
before doing any operations
on the deque.
Always acquire the lock first.
For the worker, it's a
little bit more optimized.
So what the worker will
do is optimistically try
to pop something from
the bottom of the deque.
And only if it looks like
that pop operation fails
does the worker do
something more complicated.
Only then does it try to
acquire a lock on the deque,
then try to pop something
off, see if it really
succeeds or fails, and possibly
turn to a life of crime.
So the worker's
protocol looks longer,
but that's just because
the worker implements
a special case, which is
optimized for the common case.
This is essentially where
the leave frame routine,
that we saw before, is optimized
for case one, optimized
for the pop from the
deque succeeding.
Any questions about that?
Seem clear from 30,000 feet?
Cool.
OK, so that's how a
worker steals work
from the top of
the victim's deque.
Now, that thief needs to
resume a continuation.
And this is that whole process
about jumping into the middle
of an executing function.
It already has a
frame, it already
has a [INAUDIBLE]
state going on,
and all that was established
by a different processor.
So somehow that thief
has to magically come up
with the right state and
start executing that function.
How does that happen?
Well, this has to do
with a routine that's
the complement of the set
jump routine we saw before.
The complement of set jump
is what's called long jump.
So Cilk uses, in
particular Cilk thieves,
use the long jump
function in order
to resume a stolen continuation.
Previously, in our
spawning function foo,
we had this set jump call.
And that set jump saved some
state to a local buffer,
in particular the buffer
in the stack frame of foo.
Now the thief has just created
this Cilk worker structure,
where the current
stack frame is pointing
at the stack frame of foo.
And so what the thief will
do is it'll execute a call,
it'll execute the statement,
it will execute the long jump
function, passing that
particular stack frame's buffer
and an additional argument,
and that long jump
will take the registered
state stored in the buffer,
put that registered
state into the worker,
and then let the worker proceed.
That make sense?
Any questions about that?
This is kind of a wacky routine
because, if you remember,
one of the registers
stored in that buffer
is an instruction pointer.
And so it's going to read
the instruction pointer out
of the buffer.
It's also going to read a
bunch of callee-saved registers
and stack pointers
out of the buffer.
And it is going to say,
that's my register state now,
that's what the thief says.
It just stole that
register state.
And it's going to set its RAP
to be the RAP it just read.
So what does that mean for where
the long jump routine returns?
AUDIENCE: It returns
into the stack frame
above the [INAUDIBLE]
TAO SCHARDL: Returns
the stack frame
above the one it just stole.
More or less, but
more specifically,
where in that function
does it return?
AUDIENCE: Just after the call.
TAO SCHARDL: Which call?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
TAO SCHARDL: To the
spawn bar, here?
Almost, very, very
close, very, very close.
What ends up happening is
that the long jump effectively
returns from the set
jump a second time.
This is the weird protocol
between set jump and long jump.
Set jump, you pass it a buffer,
it saves and registers state,
and then it returns.
And it returns immediately,
and on its directed vocation,
that set jump call
returns the value zero,
as we mentioned before.
Now if you invoke a long
jump using the same buffer,
that causes the processor
to effectively return
from the same set jump call.
They use the same buffer.
But now it's going to return
with a different value,
and it's going to return
with the value specified
in the second argument.
So invoking long jump
of buffer X returns
from that set jump
with the value
X. So when the thief
executes a long jump
with the appropriate buffer,
and the second argument is one,
what happens?
Can anyone walk me through this?
Oh, it's on the slide, OK.
So now that set jump effectively
returns a second time,
but now it returns
with a value one.
And now the predicate
gets evaluated.
So if not one, which
would be if false,
well don't do the consequent,
because the predicate
was false.
And that means it's going to
skip the call to spawn bar,
and it'll just fall through
and execute the stuff right
after that conditional,
which happens to be
the continuation of the spawn.
That's kind of neat.
I think that's kind of
neat, being unbiased.
Anyone else think
that's kind of neat?
Excellent.
Anyone desperately confused
about this set jump, long jump
nonsense?
Any questions you
want to ask, or just
generally confused
about why these things
exist in modern computing?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Is there any
reason you couldn't just
add, like, [INAUDIBLE]
to the instruction point
and jump over the call, instead?
TAO SCHARDL: Is there any
reason you couldn't just
add some fixed offset to
the instruction pointer
to jump over the call?
In principle, I think,
if you can statically
compute the distance
you need to jump,
then you can just add that
to RIP and let the long jump
do its thing.
Or rather, the thief
will just adopt that RIP
and end up in the right place.
What's done here is--
basically, this was the
protocol that the existing set
jump and long jump
routines implement.
And I imagine it's a bit
more flexible of a protocol
than what you strictly
need for the Cilk runtime.
And so, you know, it
ends up working out.
But if you can statically
compute that offset,
there's no reason in
principle you couldn't
adopt a different approach.
So, good observation.
Any questions?
Any other questions?
It's fine to be
generally confused
why their routines,
set jump and long jump,
with this wacky behavior.
Compiler writers have that
reaction all the time.
These are a
nightmare to compile.
Anyway, OK, so we've seen how a
thief can take some computation
off of a victim's
deque, and we've
seen how the thief
can jump right
into the middle of
an executing function
with the appropriate
register state.
Is this the end of the story?
Is there anything else
we need to talk about,
with respect to stealing?
Or, more pointedly, what else
do we not need to talk about
with respect to stealing?
You're welcome to
answer, if you like.
OK.
Hey, remember that
list of concerns
we had at the beginning?
List of requirements
is what it was called.
We will talk about
syncs, but not just yet.
What other thing was brought up?
Remember this slide
from a previous lecture?
Here's another hint.
So the register
state is certainly
part of the state of
an executing function.
What else defines a state
of an executing function?
Where doe the other state
of the function live?
It lives on the stack,
so what is there to talk
about regarding the stack?
AUDIENCE: Cactus stack.
TAO SCHARDL: The
cactus stack, exactly.
So you mentioned
before that thieves
need to implement this
cactus stack abstraction
for the Cilk runtime system.
Why exactly do we need
this cactus stack?
What's wrong with just having
the thief use the victim's
stack?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
TAO SCHARDL: The victim might
just free up a bunch of stuff
and then it's no
longer accessible.
So it can free some amount of
stuff, in particular everything
up to the function
foo, but in fact
it can't return from
the function foo
because some other--
well, assuming that the
Cilk RTS leave frame thing
is implemented--
the function foo is no
longer in the stack,
it won't ever reach it.
So it won't return
from the function foo
while another worker
is working on it.
But good observation.
There is something
else that can go wrong
if the thief just directly
uses the victim's stack.
Well, let's take a hint from
the slide we have so far.
So the example that's
going to be shown
is that the thief steals
the continuation of foo,
and then the thief is going
to call a function baz.
So the thief is using
the victim's stack,
and then it calls
a function baz.
What goes wrong?
AUDIENCE: The victim
has called something,
but underneath, there
is some other function
stack [INAUDIBLE]
TAO SCHARDL: Exactly.
The victim in this
picture, for example,
has some other functions
on its stack below foo.
So if the thief does any
function calls and is using
the same stack, it's going to
scribble all over the state
of, in this case
spawn bar, and bar,
which the victim is trying
to use and maintain.
So the thief will end up
corrupting the victim stack.
And if you think about it, it's
also possible for the victim
to call the thief stack.
They can't share
a stack, but they
do want to share some
amount of data on the stack.
They do both care
about the state of foo,
and that needs to be consistent
across all the workers.
But we at least need a separate
call stack for the thief.
We'd rather not do
unnecessary work
in order to initialize
this call stack, however.
We really need this call stack
for things that the thief might
invoke, local variables
the thief might need,
or functions that the
thief might call or spawn.
OK, so how do we implement
the cactus stack?
We have a victim stack,
we have a thief stack,
and we have a pretty cute
trick, in my opinion.
So the thief steals
its continuation.
It's going to do a little bit of
magic with its stack pointers.
What it's going to
do is it's going
to use the RBP it was given,
which points out the victim
stack, and it's going
to set the stack pointer
to point at its own stack.
So RBP is over there,
and RSP, for the thief,
is pointing to the beginning
of the thief's call stack.
And that is basically fine.
The thief can access all the
state in the function foo,
as offsets from RBP,
but if the thief
needs to do any
function calls, we
have a calling
convention that involves
saving RBP and updating RSP
in order to execute the call.
So in particular, the thief
calls the function baz,
it saves its current value
of RBP onto its own stack,
it advances RSP, it
says RBP equals RSP,
it pushes the stack frame
for baz onto the stack,
and it advances RSP
a little bit further.
And just like that, the thief is
churning away on its own stack.
So just with this magic of
RBP pointing there and RSP
pointing here, we
got our cactus stack.
Everyone follow that?
Anyone desperately confused
by this stack pointer?
Who thinks this is
kind of a neat trick?
All right, cool.
Anyone think this is a
really mundane trick?
Hopefully no one thinks
it's a mundane trick.
OK, there's like half a
hand there, that's fine.
I think this is a neat
trick, just messing around
with the stack pointers.
Are there any worries about
using RBP and RSP this way?
Any concerns that you might
think of from using these two
stack pointers as described?
In a past lecture,
briefly mentioned
was a compiler optimization
for dealing with stacks.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] We
were offsetting [INAUDIBLE]
TAO SCHARDL: Right, there
was a compiler optimization
that said, in certain cases
you don't need both the base
pointer and the stack pointer.
You can do all offsets.
I think it's actually
off the stack pointer,
and then the base
pointer becomes
an additional general
purpose register.
That optimization
clearly does not
work if you need the base
pointer stack pointer
to do this wacky trick.
The answer is that the
Cilk compiler specifically
says, if this function
has a continuation that
could be stolen, don't
do that optimization.
It's super illegal, it's very
bad, don't do the optimization.
So that ends up
being the answer.
And it costs us a
general purpose register
for Cilk functions,
not the biggest loss
in the world, all right.
There's a little
bit of time left,
so we can talk about
synchronizing computation.
I'll give you a brief
version of this.
This part gets
fairly complicated,
and so I'll give you
a high level summary
of how all of this works.
So just to page back
in some context,
we have this scenario where
different processors are
executing different parts
of our computation dag,
and one processor might
encounter a Cilk sync statement
that it can't execute because
some other processor is busy
executing a spawn
subcomputation.
Now, in this case,
P3 is waiting on P1
to finish its execution
before the sync can proceed.
And synchronization
needs to happen, really,
only on the subcomputation
that P1 is executing.
P2 shouldn't play
a role in this.
So what exactly happens
when a worker reaches a Cilk
sync before all the spawned
subcomputations return?
Well, we'd like the
worker to become a thief.
We'd rather the worker
not just sit there
and wait until all the spawned
subcomputations return.
That's a waste of a
perfectly good worker.
But we also can't let the
worker's current function
frame disappear.
There is a spawned
subcomputation
that's using that frame.
That frame is its parent.
It may be accessing
state in that frame,
it may be trying to
save a return value
to some location in that frame.
And so the frame
has to persist, even
if the worker that's
working on the frame
goes off and becomes a thief.
Moreover, in the future, that
subcomputation, we believe,
should return.
And that worker must
resume the frame
and actually execute
past the Cilk sync.
Finally, the Cilk
sync should only
apply to the nested
subcomputations
underneath its function,
not the program in general.
And so we don't allow ourselves
synchronization, just among all
the workers, wholesale.
We don't say, OK,
we've hit a sync,
every worker in the
system must reach
some point in the execution.
We only care about this
nested synchronization.
So if we think about
this, and we're
talking about nested
synchronization
for computations
under a function,
we have this notion
of cactus stack,
we have this notion of a
tree of function invocations.
We may immediately
start to think about,
well, what if we just maintain
some state, in a tree,
to keep track of who needs
this to synchronize with whom,
which computations
are waiting on which
other computations to finish?
And, in fact, that's essentially
what the Cilk runtime
system does.
It maintains a tree of
states called full frames,
and those full
frames store state
for the parallel
subcomputations.
And those full frames
keep track of which
subcomputations are standing and
how they relate to each other.
This is a high level
picture of a full frame.
There are lots of details
highlighted, to be honest.
But at 30,000 feet,
a full frame keeps
track of a bunch of information
for the parallel execution--
I know, I'm giving you the
quick version of this--
including pointers
to parent frames
and possibly pointers to child
frames, or at least the number
of outstanding child frames.
The processors, when
there's a system,
work on what are called
active full frames.
In the diagram,
those full frames
are the rounded rectangles
highlighted in dark blue.
Other full frames in the system
are, what we call, suspended.
They're waiting on some
subcomputation to return.
That's what a full frame
tree can look like under,
some execution.
Let's see how a full frame
tree can come into being, just
by working through an animation.
So suppose we have some
worker with a bunch of spawned
and called frames on its deque.
No other workers have
anything on their deques.
And finally, some
worker wants to steal.
And I'll admit, this animation
is crafted slightly, just
to make the pictures
a little bit nicer.
It can look more
complicated in practice,
don't worry, if that was
actually a worry of yours.
So what's going to
happen, the thief
is going to take some frames
from the top of the victim's
deque.
And it's actually going to
steal not just those frames,
but the whole full frame
structure along with it.
The full frame structure
is just represented
with this rounded rectangle.
In fact, it's a
constant size thing.
But the thief is going to take
the whole full frame structure.
And it's going to give the
victim a brand new full frame
and establish the child to
parent pointer in the victim's
new full frame.
That's kind of weird.
It's not obvious why the thief
would take the full frame
as it's stealing computation,
at least not from one step.
But we can see why it helps,
just given one more step.
So let's fast forward
this picture a little bit,
and now we have another worker
try to steal some computation,
and we have a little
bit more stuff going on.
So this worker might randomly
select the last worker
on the right, steal computation
from the top of its deque,
and it's going to steal
the full frame along
with the deque frames.
And because it stole
the full frame,
all pointers to that full frame
from any child subcomputations
are still valid.
The child's
computation on the left
still points to the
correct full frame.
The full frame that was
stolen has the parent context
of that child, and so
we need to make sure
that pointer is still good.
If it created a new
full frame for itself,
then you would have to update
the child pointers somehow,
and that requires more
synchronization and a more
complicated protocol.
Synchronization is expensive,
protocols are complicated.
This ends up saving
some complexity.
And then it creates a
frame for the child,
and we can see
this process unfold
just a little bit further.
And we'll hold off for a few
steals, we end up with a tree.
We have two children
pointing to one parent,
and one of those children
has its own child.
Great.
Now suppose that some worker
says, oh, I encountered a sync,
can I synchronize?
In this case, the worker has an
outstanding child computation
so it can't synchronize.
And so we can't
recycle the full frame,
we can't recycle any of
the stack for this child.
And so, instead, the worker
will suspend this full frame,
turning it from dark blue to
light blue in our picture,
and it goes and becomes a thief.
The program has
ample parallelism.
What do we expect to typically
happen when the program
execution reaches a Cilk sync?
We're kind of out
of time, so I think
I'm just going to spoil the
answer for this, unless anyone
has a guess handy.
So what's the common
case for a Cilk sync?
For the sake of
time, the common case
is that the executing function
has no outstanding children.
All the workers
on the system were
busy doing their
own thing, there
is no synchronization
that's necessary.
And so how does the
runtime optimize this case?
It ends up having
the full frame,
uses some bits of an
associated stack frame,
in particular the flag field.
And that's why, when we look
at the compiled code for a Cilk
sync, we see some conditions
that evaluate the flags
within the local stack frame.
That's just an optimization to
say, if you don't need a sync,
don't do any computation,
otherwise some steals really
did occur, go ahead and execute
the Cilk RTS sync routine.
There are a bunch of
other runtime features.
If you take a look at that
picture for a long time,
you may be dissatisfied with
what that implies about some
of the protocols.
And there's a lot more code
within the runtime system
itself, to implement a
variety of other features such
as support for C++ exceptions,
reducer hyperobjects,
and a form of IDs
called pedigrees.
We won't talk about that today.
I'm actually all out of time.
Thanks for listening to all this
about the Cilk runtime system.
Feel free to ask any
questions after class.